do you remember that one tweet by Joe
Jorgensen Tyler I don't know if you have
it or not she is and all of a sudden we
get this tweet about uh what do you call
it uh uh racism and black lives matter
and we need to be so if you can make
that it's not enough to be passively not
racist we must be actively
anti-uh races black lives don't mean
standing in a solidarity with a morning
black community As We Fight Together to
end qualify immunity police brutality
sentencing disparities and the War on
Drugs not support of any organization by
by that name okay so to me I see that
and I uh I don't know how you guys
process it I'm going to speak for myself
you guys can't say Pat you're full of
you know you have no clue what you're
talking about I see that and I see
somebody caving in to PC community and
you know political correctness just kind
of like hey beating you down you better
give yourself okay let's throw this out
there so maybe we can get some
independent voters who are agreeing with
black lives okay let's throw so I can
get some of the democratic voters to
come to yeah so that that argument then
then all of a sudden the people that are
true Libertarians are like wait a minute
the that's not what I believe in I'm out
well I mean look I was very vocal and
very critical about that tweet as well
as a bunch of other ones it was just
yeah it was just awful and completely
tone deaf I mean it's also like she said
it while the longest sustained riots in
modern American history were going on I
mean it's like you know like people were
terrified in almost every major city
across the country businesses being
destroyed and then it's just like well
it it's also not libertarian at all the
libertarianism really has nothing to say
about how you feel about other people if
you are passively not racist that's more
than good enough we don't require anyone
to be actively anti-racist whatever that
means
um the truth is that look I was very
critical of Joe Jorgensen during this
campaign I think that's why a lot of her
people around uh her don't like me very
much and why they gave her some bad
information that she came and shared
with you on the show um but I think that
it does
Libertarians if we're gonna look like 10
to the fundraising issue before I think
as far as National candidates go the the
truth is that
um Ron Paul at the time broke
fundraising records uh Bernie Sanders
then came in and smashed those and they
didn't do it by going to private Equity
guys 6 million on MySpace in 24 hours
that's right that's right Ron Paul yes
it was and it broke records and he
didn't even set it up he literally just
got into the camera and said things that
people really appreciated and so what I
think is that the role for Libertarians
here is that we're not going to
out-compete Democrats and Republicans in
terms of getting more money from private
Equity or big Banks or something like
that because we're not offering them
what Democrats and Republicans are the
truth is that if the libertarian agenda
were to ever be put in place big Banks
would make way less money than they make
right now we're the party who wants to
abolish the Federal Reserve and make
sure there's never Banker bailouts again
and that they don't have unlimited
access to easy money and that they can
you know like yeah I bet if I could
borrow money at zero percent interest
rate and then loan it out to the public
uh for at four percent I could do pretty
good making money 22 but we're trying to
end that scheme but what we can do is
talk to the American people who are
being ripped off by this whole system
and get them excited so that's so the
problem with Joe Jorgensen is that when
you're so out of touch with what's going
on in the culture right now and you just
say something like this that rightly by
you is perceived as caving in to a
literal mob
um that doesn't get them riled up it in
this time period while Joe Jorgensen is
tweeting that the American people have
the government has perpetrated one of
the greatest crimes against the American
people in modern American history which
were the lockdowns kicking tens of
millions of people out of work with no
legal justification just under emergency
power Governor decrees we're many
dictators now it's illegal now for you
to go to work and at the same time they
have raped the American people just
completely looted the treasury and
bailed out every giant Corporation in
the country it was like the the most
heinous crime committed against the
American people and in that moment and
to stand up and say you know what the
problem is you average American you're
not anti-racist enough that's the real
issue that's what Libertarians have to
say awful message didn't it
yeah I mean I lost all my income
immediately I mean I bled through my
savings in about four months I mean the
um the closures the covid closures are
definitely what red pilled me so hard
um I think uh Joe's tweet is just
indicative of the old format of
Libertarians trying to court both sides
of of the social of the um the culture
War but we're so deep into it now that
if you don't know that what you're D if
you don't Define what the DNA of
libertarian libertarianism is today like
how how do we standardize any type of
messaging because that's very contrary
to the opinions of like people on this
panel that want to see Libertarians move
more to the right on these issues well
and also I agree with that and also just
kind of knowing where your best
potential you know like I want everyone
to be a Libertarian but I could also
recognize that there's certain groups
that are probably a little bit more
likely to respond to our message and
what you have going on if you if you
have your finger on the pulse of the
country is that you had
um you have a lot of people like on the
political right half of the country who
align with a lot of our views a lot of
people who really are fed up with like
the wars and the the Deep State all the
three-letter agencies that that are fed
up with the lockdowns that are I mean
even after all the Republican Governors
by and large were awful on the lockdowns
we talk about like the two who were good
like the Santas and and gnome the rest
of them all basically went along with
the program
um and then you have a bunch of people
who historically have been more left
liberals who are completely turned off
by all this woke insanity and are kind
of leaving that so what you're playing
to with this message is the people who
what love the woke insanity and are left
liberals right this of all the groups
this is the least likely to bear fruit
for you so it's just even on top of it
being incorrect it's also just
strategically stupid
where I wonder like who are you
processing issues with before you put a
message like this because you're
speaking on be half of 4.5 4.6 million
people that voted for this concept this
philosophy just four years ago like who
are you strategizing with to say let's
go and do this that's when I was asking
about Spike but Jessica you voted for
Obama no wait right you were you were
you were more on the liberal side
Democratic side so what caused you to
say because everybody's selling their
philosophies what got you to the Tipping
Point to say you know what I kind of
like what these guys stand for
um just on Joe's tweet again do you
think that's indicative of the fact that
she's an educator and we know how woke
the how woke that went so being
education I would just like to weigh in
Joe has didn't even know that was made
it was from a a speech that was written
for her at the convention and they
clipped it for the Tweet so I I just
want to make a point that like she
didn't do that I don't know how Joe
jorgensen's never been on her Twitter
but but I do want to talk about this by
the way what you just said yeah what you
just said I hate to say this eliminates
it from ever running as the face of the
libertarian party what you just said
right there because if you can't speak
for yourself I'm sorry I don't want I
don't want you at the at the White House
and if you do Outsource that then it's
your response
I want to know what you're all about
yeah
in the wake of the killing of George
Floyd and Brianna Taylor and the
protests and the riots that that sparked
there was an excellent opportunity for
Liberty parents to talk about the same
system that had unaccountable police
officers that were doing those things as
well as that same criminal justice
system that was letting people take over
entire communities and Riot and pillage
and burn down buildings and homes it was
a great opportunity to do that that's
what should have been done that's what I
was trying to do in my little corner is
saying the same system that this group's
mad at is the same system that this
group is mad at and we should be talking
about that instead of playing to the
black lives matter versus all lives
matter culture War good cop bad cop
routine saying you're all being scammed
and lied to the way forward is to fix
these specific policies or end these
specific policies that led to what we're
experiencing right now and if we do that
then we can both Reach people across the
board we can actually have a moment of
unification and we can wake up some
people that are looking at all this and
saying I don't think anyone is speaking
to the actual solution to this
when you go once hard one side or the
other when you when you start uh using
too much of the the verbiage and the and
the the tone and Narrative of one side
or the other you're signaling well I
actually kind of support this side well
if you're trying to get elected then
you're basically saying yeah I'm like
this guy except I'm less likely to win
or I'm like this guy except I'm less
likely to win but if instead you provide
a stark contrast and say no no here's
why they're both wrong I hated when I
would get interviewed and they'd say do
you agree with uh Trump on this or do
you agree with Biden on this and I'd say
here's why they're both wrong and here's
what Libertarians believe and that was
the problem with that tweet and with a
lot of other things is that instead of
trying to provide a stark contrast
between the Republicans and Democrats
and how they both work together to fail
us on this instead it was well on this I
agree with this side more on that I
agree with that side more well why are
we relevant then so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]